hey what's going on is Bilborough and
it's time for a very special edition of
the Monday morning podcast of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
podcast whatever the hell you want to
call it I have a very special guest here
this is a guy I've been a fan of since I
don't know like the first time I saw him
82 or 83 please welcome drumming legend
mr. Kenny Aronoff yeah man what's going
on dude it's so cool to see you because
the first time I saw it was a buddy of
mine in Chicago said you gotta see this
guy I went can I swear on this film yeah
yeah yeah Massachusetts or something
yeah I didn't know I always thought you
were in New York I didn't I - I'm not -
so my mom came grew up in the Bronx
because I live grew up in Exeter which
you we were talking about in Stockbridge
I put some reason I adapted that New
York thing yeah it was not that pocket
car and Apple was like [ __ ] you
know like thee but that's a weird part
of Massachusetts he's talking exit 2 on
the Mass Pike where I was telling you I
had one of the worst gigs and Lee
Massachusetts starting out but you know
leaving there people throwing that time
yeah they would just they were bored is
what I thought and they just won't
looking for someone to beat the [ __ ] out
of and I look like Ron Howard so that
was going to be an easy night for them I
just remember standing up there and so
bad wanted to say something I know all
they wanted me to do was just say that
one thing and they like because they had
this look on their face like come on
come on freckles say it and now it's
just like I am gonna get like curb
stomped so I didn't say [ __ ] and I got
paid and they were like following me
around like this group and they like
they threw this dinner roll at me they
missed and it was weird it was like this
where I've told this story before was
like it was like this function room and
next door to it was another function
room was part of this restaurant in the
other room was like a bachelor party and
there was no closed door and they just
saw me standing there Baughman in this
restaurant and I just became this
entertainment thing and I was it
downtown Lee is there a downtown ya know
it was it was I remember it was like I
remember pulling out of there and it was
just like this remind me that that bar
that they went to in Porky's remember
that there
in the middle of the [ __ ] woods like
that I'm sure it's all developed now but
I remember when I finally build out my
little piece-of-shit Ranger I had my
head out the window like Ace Ventura
goes they were just laughing yeah I
probably took you know five years off my
life that night
so anyways but that's a weird part of
Massachusetts where there's like there's
Patriots fans and Giants fans you start
to get into that it's 20 minutes from
the border of on the border yeah so
there's Yankee fans and Red Sox fans
it's kind of like Connecticut like you
know sort of halfway through yeah you
start getting out that way like who do
you root for so I guess I don't know but
your parents you said your mom was from
the Bronx
he's from the box and my dad was from
Paterson New Jersey and then they all
kind of lived in New York for a while
and then they my dad got he was studying
paper and chemistry so in lis there was
a mill there's all these little mills up
there in New England on the river and he
worked for a division of kimberly-clark
help they of course [ __ ] in the drinking
water out there we used to say man if
you're in a boat and you fall into that
river you asked it'll burn you alive
I don't know they'd you see it stunk in
the summer it was so bad they just dump
chemicals in there you know just wash it
out baby [ __ ] like that anymore do they
I know no not not at all it's all good
water that's why we got the water the
earth I know in the air
I know that's what's so [ __ ] up about
all this [ __ ] that people always talking
about on social media like that's this
big goddamn deal like fat shaming and
all of this [ __ ] it's like dude those
are problems problems are so down the
[ __ ] game as far as like what is
going on right now yeah all this [ __ ]
you know some place you have within one
month they're gonna run out of water
period I can't I can't listen I can't
listen anything cuz it just because
there's no [ __ ] solution no one pays
attention and then if you try to address
it conservatives are lame liberals and
levels brain conservatives and then they
just keep plowing ahead and I don't want
to hear what I'm gonna say what are you
gonna say let's not all about like you
know people you know people [ __ ]
students they're like little
kindergartner still I don't care how old
you are
I
think the world is evolving at all maybe
with technology technology what's the
same [ __ ] I cannot believe I cook you to
[ __ ] about that and who doesn't [ __ ]
about that oh really you really that
uptight about that holy [ __ ]
right now I know what you mean or like
you know some big issues which I won't
mention with a squabbling look dude just
make a little adjust this is thing you
now you have to dance around cuz you
like some big issues that I'm not gonna
remember you're upset about this and I
don't know every issue that you're
[ __ ] talking about but you can't
bring it up because then you have like
you have eighty soccer moms and this is
thing eighty soccer moms will actually
make the news cuz they're gonna talk
about that okay you or whatever [ __ ]
reason so you got it you got to make the
news that I got a chance between the
raindrops I'm gonna get my ass kid we
got to get some padding on this table
and he's sort of shipping of weight yeah
so anyway check so man I'm gonna get my
ass kicked right now but I call look at
I grew up in western mass super liberal
super democratic you know you know just
everybody just when they both Democratic
all the way down doesn't matter if it
was Hitler if he's a Democrat he's on
dem grand besides I I'm just blown away
I call them vicious liberals now oh yeah
dogs living out here I know it's curly
people are so like a real true liberal
was my dad a liberal my dad you know we
grew up Jewish but my dad would listen
and to Hitler talk just to see what he
had to say wouldn't yell at him he would
talk and then he tell Hitler that he was
[ __ ] in so many words but he would
least taught me he like knew the guy
reason why no but I just say talking to
the TV that was the ultimate like [ __ ]
Odd Couple movie with me like roommates
in college or some [ __ ] no actually my
dad was bombing Hitler and well it was
he wasn't a bombers it just leveled
Hitler you know but my point is my dad
was a true liberal he would listen to
anybody didn't matter what is but
nowadays it's like I call them vicious
slippers they're like they're more
conservative and radical and totally a
true liberal is somebody who listens and
and will at least accept somebody else's
opinion no matter how radical it is
liberal is your open mark cept the fact
that you have that up
you'll listen to and everything boy yeah
but you this viciousness is like it's
like no there's destroying our ears they
will just if you had like it's basically
we're liberal think what we think but if
you don't we're gonna go after your
career and it's like it's no different
than I remember what to happen to the
Dixie Chicks when they just expressed
that opinion about the current president
yeah and I remember that clocks news was
saying like well they have a right to
state their opinion and we have a right
to have you know state our opinion it's
like you didn't state your opinion
you've stayed your opinion then you
systematically tried to destroy their
[ __ ] ability to earn a living
that's not tit for tat no you know what
I mean so what that's saying that
sandbox stuff but you feel a bunch of
little kids still how'd we get on that I
don't know what I wanted tux I know
everybody always talk to you about
drumming and all that [ __ ] I don't what
nobody doesn't talk to you about to you
how I'm gonna say I hold you up but I'm
old okay you're all how do you stay in
the [ __ ] shape you're in
yeah you shredded yeah well you know
this is me kind of out of shape because
uh I'm so busy right now but you know
what happened was in a certain point in
my life it was early it was like going
out with Mellencamp and I might have
been 27 mm-hm
coming out of a pretty wild time party
wise you know and certainly went this
ain't right I think clicked in my head
now I'm not saying I remember what party
you were at and what you were looking at
to be like I'm a part of this I can't
judge let's a five-year period do 19
something to 19 something that party you
mean it was like I was open for business
it was was it was it something that it
was a feeling that was gradually working
at you or just just one night just
boogie nights [ __ ] happen you were just
like I I gotta stop this well first of
all the environment I was in was just it
just food just a bunch of kids in rock
bands is partying and [ __ ] was available
you know and and you drank and and you
and I had abundance of energy so you
know I I just if I drank too much I wake
up and that's gay that sucks and then
just go on all day but what happened
suddenly I just I said my stomach
started feeling like
couldn't when I was eating I was like it
was wasn't digesting food real good I
just beat myself up I wasn't taking care
of myself and during that time I was I
was always a jock I was a three-letter
man jock in high school
lacrosse ski team and soccer East Coast
[ __ ] you know and I end up going to
UMass for music in my freshman year I
was on the lacrosse team that was the
number one lacrosse number nine the
cause team in the conference at Amherst
or Boston Amherst oh god I went there
there's a party school do you know I
used to have like route when I was
growing up once a year somebody died at
a Southwest they jump off the building
or something no they would ride the
elevators oh they would ride the
elevator surfing and somebody every year
would fall down the [ __ ] shaft oh did
you did you go there I went to UMass I
went everywhere yeah I want every kid I
[ __ ] I whenever I went to UMass
Boston yeah NC State Emerson was
accepted at Northeastern I think I can't
remember I just I just sort of bounced
around and I hated school yeah I hated
it I just wasn't at just looking your
thing I did yeah I just didn't give up I
just want to get the [ __ ] out of there
and I wanted to do son I wanted to play
drums I wanted to joke around I wanted
to drink I wanted like a normal kid
really yeah that's what I wanted to do
and there was a few subjects that I
would I would like yeah some history but
like that [ __ ] old old old [ __ ] yeah
and I'm sick yeah I know I had a purpose
in college so it worked out but Michael
you went you'd like I would survive
hardcore classical I know there was no
School of Rock Berkeley was still mostly
a jazz school scene my family everybody
went to college so you know at that time
it's like you do it so I'm gonna be a
music major and I was self-taught
drummer you know and there was this one
kid in stock which it was getting better
and I can what do you do well I'm taking
lessons from this percussion from the
Boston Symphony Orchestra art depressed
lived in you'll know nya no no no he's
lived in Newton no I remember Newton
yeah so um it's a first time so I went
okay I'm gonna take a lesson when this
guy excels you're competitive you know
just being a jock and all and I had long
hair down my shoulder so I was a hippie
jock you know so and I was always
playing in a band I was you know always
I was really popular in high school and
I have identical twin brother so we both
were in the bands both on sports teams
it was long had long hair yeah heckle
and Jeckle did you start lethal weapon
so um I go down there I'm never forget
go down to Newton on a bus Greyhound bus
from Lee that's it firmly but I was
hungover because I had been hanging out
with the varsity football team varsity
soccer team and the cheerleaders the
night before drinking vodka on a
mountain you know what a is fire
drinking vodka just ice and at night yep
and didn't get laid but you know I was
hanging with those oh you know two years
in high school that's old of chick I
don't I mean that's like big time it
bigger tits everything is more developed
you know
so anyway stakes are higher yeah I get
to Newton I'm like I was in the back
probably puking in a bus and I get there
this is art the press this is old school
it goes what's your name this is Kenny
Kenny what Kenny Aronoff he says what
have you prepared for me today
Oh No yeah well if you put what well do
you play mallets I'm like what's mallets
this is marimba vibes I said no I'm
getting smaller and smaller okay this is
old school guy man this guy's hardcore
then goes would you prepare a timpani
pieces so I I don't play timpani what do
you play this is what's like drum set
well come on down here let's say see
place in Tulsa puts on spinning wheels
by blood sweat and tears and I actually
been jamming to that and my barn I had a
barn in western mass that's what he had
all rock bands my parents played every
we always had the rock bands rehearsing
at my place said a barn and my parents
loved it because they the kids were at
home even we were smoking pot and
drinking they just there we were you
know so let's sit down in 30 minutes he
rips me off the
off the drumset and pointed to a rubber
black pad well how did you feel that you
were playing you'll go a spin we are I'm
gonna nail this I was feeling it I
thought I was good
he didn't think so so he puts down the
pad basically he kicked my ass and that
was a pivotal point in my life I'm like
a lot of kids would have gone [ __ ] this
man I don't need you I'm playing in a
rock band I'm getting laid I'm having
fun what do I need this [ __ ] [ __ ] but
something clicked and I have to say it's
in my DNA that this is good for me
and I my dad bought me an old set of buy
before $300 from Carol's music in New
York and now I had that I think your
sports background gave you that that you
then made you not afraid of like new
information this got this guy's being
hard on me because the guy seems like a
coach to me he was totally cool yeah
you're walking in like a blue chip
prospect eh I got this all down and then
just because you don't know [ __ ] yeah it
was noted that the because back then you
don't mean the coaches back then were
like marine sergeants it was back then
there was no hand-holding it was no
coddling there was no entitlement there
was none of this lazy they look at
athletes now like they're all a bunch of
date rapists and all that say with frat
boys and all that and they they totally
lose like the confidence that you get
from playing sports the the ability to
work with a group the ability to get
your [ __ ] ass kicked and lose and
shake it off like links to cup water win
the next quarter it is yeah you learn
all this great stuff but now it's just
kind of you know it's sort of like the
nerd time so like their perspective and
they don't [ __ ] play sports so their
perspective of it is Perez is as [ __ ]
up to be fair is the jocks perspective
of them you know well you know what
while they're sitting there being
entitled to wait for [ __ ] to happen and
and in pussyfooting around I'm gonna go
over them and take what they're waiting
for
and I'm sorry I am not letting down on
it that's how it's all work so I mean
back then they you know took my parents
were really sensitive and cool but bad
get you ass up there was no no you know
hand-holding or entitlement I'm grateful
that I sided with the teacher the
teachers said your kids acting like an
[ __ ]
they would look at you what's your
problem is acting like an [ __ ]
instead take out this cellphone video
and then the teacher has to apologize
because you're not raising your kids
right now you're dumping this douche off
at school and they have to deal with
your bad parenting for six hours hours a
[ __ ] week I mean T teachers are
grossly grossly underpaid Oh grossly
underpaid those why would you want to be
a teacher it's like you got not only you
got everybody against you or not now
with all these little [ __ ] kids then
and you do anything it seems they take
out a camera and then that they're
automatically right dude it's brutal man
I don't know okay we do sound like a
bunch of old guys going oh my God he's
kids today but there is an element of
like jeez and I was welcome you know
what I miss I'm going it off shake it
off okay so check this out I really
believe that people should embrace the
fear their anger embarrassment failure
all that negative stuff I believe you
should squeeze it hug it throw it away
and get your [ __ ] ass and gear and
move forward what are some of your top
like five or whatever three four five
most embarrassing moments that you had
on your way up to becoming the worst was
so I know we keep getting off eventually
studied classical music I got to go to
school so I said I get into you Mayer
Sparrow Lee beginning to UMass barely
but the guy he put up me like some
marimba music I never played might play
but puts up a site meeting it and I suck
I miss every note he takes away I wait
no give it back it's a marimba that's
not the Lionel Hampton thing is that
survives that's why I remembers wooden
it's long okay and you learn classical
like violin music on it so that you can
learn you know about harmony and scales
and you become not just a drummer but
you come a well-rounded musician so I
didn't realize this but when I wrote
read wrote my book sex dumb drug why
because I I really am a fighter fight
guy not a fight or flight guy that's DNA
you know so anyway I demanded that music
back and I I just wouldn't give up and
that's he went I'm gonna I'll long and I
love teaching this guy this guy wants to
have work so bond lies it was just chick
I'll see you bombed on that thing and he
was just like this isn't right for you
and you you know he I you're part of you
when you auditioned for school and
classical you have to perform on snare
drum you have a piece you prepare and
then he's gonna want to ask you
rudiments technique and then sight read
music same with mallets you prepare
pieces you can say we'll give me a C
major scale
give me a D minor scale give me a play
in our pen she'll give me an Augmented
chord and then and they give you a sheet
what they're gonna test you on but then
they put that music up that you know
you've never seen you gotta play in
rhythm and and hit all the notes and I
always sucked at that then madama
graduated Indiana University I want to
Concerto Competition where I was [ __ ] I
could even play it I got it it's a
violin concerto that I saw Itzhak
Perlman play as his encore virtuosic
beautiful piece and I knew in my senior
year I was gonna have to play a
virtuosic
violin concerto or violin piece on ber
inba to pass Indiana I went UMass to
four years of Indiana which is the
number one school that's cool my teacher
was like a Navy SEAL commander it's like
he would try to wash you out because the
school is number one and I had to keep
that status so anybody who was not
capable they would wash you out
he would just I'm gonna get to the
embarrassing moment this guy walk in and
he'd be like look taking notes on the
last student and he'd hit the desk which
meant give me my your lesson book he'd
open it up you still taking notes she's
looking at it and go oh f-sharp harmonic
minor two octaves don't you write hand
three four I'm still standing it with my
bookbag he looks at me goes are you
happy here at Indiana University Kenny
do you want to stay here I'm like holy
[ __ ] Jesus when you walk in don't catch
your ass in front of the instrument and
be ready to play you never know when a
conductors gonna walk and say three four
let's go you have to be ready he was
training you to be a marine and this
stuff carried carried forward into my
entire life
so anyway I'm at I'm at UMass and this
is hot Junior
this chicks talking about jealous it's
as hot as you can be in classical music
it's not like rock and roll but my shoes
the hottest shoes
to go hot hot yeah I hear ya powdered
wig he's nice tits in a pot of wick yeah
buddy I hear that she's gonna go to this
place called Aspen School of Music it's
run by Juilliard
so all I'm thinking is chick you know
I'm like I'm with a god I gotta go
I don't realize it's run by Julia which
is the number two school in the country
and it's it's I'm not gonna get in so
but the sheet they tell you got to
prepare in the audition from four to
three out of the four different areas
snare drum timpani mallets and multiple
percussion so I auditioned on a fork
because I'm not that great yet so night
the pieces are you know kind of like
beginner intermediate I send the tape in
no I don't hear from them last day of
school got my dad station wagon I'm
gonna leave UMass so my summer was just
study with Arthur press had this cool
band Allman Brothers Band and I had this
girlfriend yeah they didn't know about
the chalice but anyway I I'm leavin
Amherst and I went oh [ __ ] I forgot to
check my mail and go back and I pull the
mail I had some mail it looks like I got
a check oh [ __ ] what which is this open
up accepted to Aspen two weeks before
away so it must have been a somebody
must have cancelled cuz you don't tell
somebody two weeks before I so two weeks
later I go to Aspen by the way the chick
didn't show up she didn't go all the
classical she did not go so I'm there
dude
I was they went to D two or none worst
percussionist there all these kids with
Juilliard prep they've been playing
timpani Miraval when they were in
diapers you know they was just I'm doing
scalp dudududududududu and they're going
playing these Bach partida's and
virtuosic [ __ ] just Anderson I have a
picture of me with all those people and
the funny thing is kind of like your
story worst guy there I became the most
at me as far as famous visual guy out of
all of them lot some went became lawyers
some became this came that one guy did
get at empty job
in the san francisco orchestra which is
big but nobody became visible and
Rockstar like me I'm not saying I'm
better I'm just saying it's just ironic
I thought okay I thought when I was
there as a piece of [ __ ] cuz okay one
day I'm in rehearsal Nach orchestra
rehearsal we're playing a Tchaikovsky
Symphony or something or Romeo and
Juliet and the Orcas is going and then
they stop in the cymbals go it's a hole
for me well I'm counting I didn't know
what I should have done is study the
music and just pretty much memorized
eight measures before you come in so
you'll have to count you don't worry
about counting the violins not me I'm
going 100 102 103 104 why not wait wait
a sec wait 100 100 1 2 3 4 101 102 101
Oh was that world - oh [ __ ] I come in
the wrong place
this [ __ ] he didn't just go
excuse me he went boom playing cymbals
the whole works - turns around I'm
peeing in my pants I said me embarrassed
and he says don't you know when to come
in count for me ok so I start counting I
kind of like 200 measures he's just
trying to ridicule me who's an [ __ ]
and I get to the point where I'm
supposed to come in I don't play just
what did you play I said you said count
can't say play Jesus this surprised me
that [ __ ] was that movie where the
guy was playing the drum Blache yeah the
guy kept yelling I could I couldn't
watch the movie yeah I was just like
just join a different band why would you
sit here and let somebody if I had a kid
let somebody talk to them to that level
I know it's like one thing I'm just
trying to make you better but like when
it gets the point somebody's like taking
their life out on you you know or at
least push back yeah you know one of you
then won't you go [ __ ] yourself give me
one of those yeah he'll respect you more
instead of
I don't know that kind of goes against
what we've been talking about earlier
you saying like you know you gotta take
a little bit there's the boat you know
it's a scale it's always a scale what
weighs heavier me punch them in the face
or verbally tell them and then get my
ass kicked and fired is that more
important than hanging in here and just
getting better all right make a decision
it's always a scale to me you know it's
like the coach it's up your ass or the
teacher in many cases or some of the
people have worked for and you go you
know I've never people telling me I
won't make sure your name's sake I can't
believe you put up with that [ __ ] and
I'm like well number one hit single on
the radio right now no no I mean it's
like you didn't go on the road with them
who's just a studio gig knows full-blown
all in the routing yeah you know I've
been so [ __ ] lucky in this business
and I also think it's because when I
finally started doing [ __ ] in this
business where like it used to be back
in the day there was like 20 giant
slices of pie
yeah so there was always a sort of like
20 people at any moment who just could
snap their fingers in the whole world
had to move yeah and now it just seems
like each one of those 20 slices has
been chopped up a million times so it's
like you you can't be an [ __ ] anymore
you know what I mean they keep told sort
of like can't be that you know Tippin
over the craft service table and I
refuse to come out of my trailer and are
you telling me that my career is over
since we've been talking band no I
definitely like I've never on any like
on any acting gig everybody I've ever
worked with his they always showed up on
time yeah and you hear all these stories
I've never had I've only been of course
doing that stuff like the last few years
but I've never run into that but then
you always heard these stories you know
I first got into this business about you
know people would get like a sitcom and
then all of a sudden the creators of the
show are banned from the set yeah and
they refuse to do the lines their tank
and table reads because they're mad at
the writers all of that [ __ ] I I never
saw any of that well that's because that
was somebody's sitting a there's a
hundred people behind you ready to take
your gig for a third of the pay yeah in
rock and roll oh I hear say you want to
go on tour I won't mention a name some
stadiums and they're paying the
musicians that I'm like - are you
kidding me I said that's I used to make
that in a day recording they used to and
the thing is is that this kids who go
out and do it for half as much and share
a room or sleep on the floor just to do
it
I you know might unbelievable friend of
mine tell me about that doing like some
giant like they say like we're the
Falcons of plan
yeah and he was just gonna do it if you
knew the money they will make it is just
like the the artist gets all of it and
then you know yeah we're going back I'm
sleeping in the bathtub this other guys
sleeping in the bed and blah blah and
it's just like what happens the
accountants got control of the business
the counts in the business people and
where the artist thought they and they
suck up to the artist and artists are
happy because you're saving money you're
saving well I'm saving you this amount
of money if you put these people there
and you pay them this and you're this
and you're that and you know that'll
give anybody a hard-on you know
especially if you were a struggling
musician there's a point in a forking
world where I think a struggling
musician either becomes the person that
was kind of keeping them down or they go
that's not the way to treat people and
they most of them don't they become just
like that or worse I've worked with
these guys were you know they kind of
like they got screwed yeah they got
screwed by the label they got screwed
like by managers I get screwed yeah but
that doesn't mean you screw your band I
saw a guy I saw a guy recently I was
watching one at least it's called
sideman there was something I think or
did something that there's a guy in that
and either the black blues guys no no no
this is just talking about higher gun
like a higher yeah yeah like exactly we
do okay so this guy basically that's guy
was in that one I what's the story all
right was the Nine Inch Nails all I know
all those guys both sides so there was a
guy I know in a band he becomes the guy
that was treating him a certain way he
went and became that guy yeah Frank goes
hey man he ran he goes you're going on
to a giant house the end of this tour
I'm going back to lives my parents he go
to the basement
yeah he goes you want to make some money
write a record so he went out he wrote a
record and then he turned around and he
did the exact same thing to all those
people I thought he would have eased off
the gas
little bit you know any was like now
[ __ ] you man that's this is the game
this is the game so I said I watched it
I didn't know how to feel about it like
I was sitting there going like well I
wouldn't do that [ __ ] but it's easy for
me as a comedian because you know we
don't have to split the money as yours
with like other bands yes you know it's
yeah all the other shift taxes and well
I mean that but the but you know not not
to defend him or that position is that
that's the business makes could make you
feel like you know I got just beat up so
much that now it's my turn to be on top
and [ __ ] everybody else that kind of
thing it can do that but there was that
that was a time like that and stand-up
it was a certain Comedy Club and it was
just a really bad time for it and it
just had this really negative vibe and
there was all of these guys that at the
time had TV shows and movie careers and
they would come down to the club and
they would do like an hour and a half
two hours not worked out any material
just leaning on the mic stand guy asked
so what else is going on and just
showing off that they could burn the
light and meanwhile would bump like 20
comics and like people just start saying
you know and then you couldn't say I'm
going home because then the club would
get mad at you so you would literally go
from heaven like an 11 o'clock spot to
waiting around to like 2:30 in the
morning there would be nobody there and
this was every [ __ ] night and you
felt that energy in the back of the club
of certain comics being like man I can't
wait til I get a [ __ ] sitcom I'm
going up there and I'm gonna [ __ ]
burn the light I'm gonna make everybody
else way and fortunately right around
that time the Seinfeld show was ending
and I would never forget I was down in
the improv on Melrose and Jerry Seinfeld
came in to do a set and he had to do 20
minutes and he did 20 minutes he came up
with shell that worked and then in the
middle he tried out some new stuff had a
big closer and then he just went awry
any questions bing-bang-boom
and done and walked in that same Club
that you know this was a that's a great
example that's what I was sitting in it
and I remember and then wanting him oh
don't leave you know leave him want more
all of that [ __ ] he was 12 total [ __ ]
Pro
and I just remember thinking like that's
how you do it that's how you do it and
and good thing you were there and every
comic like who watched left excited that
they got to see him work and do his
thing and then you don't give a [ __ ] if
you get bumped 20 minutes to see
Seinfeld but you know if he went up
there and for [ __ ] two hours yeah
torture there was a meandering you know
had a little [ __ ] piece of you know
just going up dad being famous just be
famous and the fact that he didn't do I
meant that always stuck with me like all
right that's that side effect of without
you what you aspire to be that classy
and that professional that's the kid
okay time for some reads here all right
son basket everyone all right might
health seeking friends the days of not
following through with resolutions are
because the days of son basket are just
beginning which means you I mean which
means you're going to keep your
resolution this year you fat bastard
because son basket is make makes it
easier than ever and today you can get
$35 off your first order when you go to
son basket calm / birbee you are are we
when you have healthy meals regularly
delivered to your door with son basket
and you don't eat ice cream afterwards
you're gonna drop the weight it's easy
to stay on track I'm talking about
ingredients like organic produce
responsibly raised me hey it's past your
bedtime get back on the bar sustainably
source are my daughter's love them
sustainably sourced fish organic
pasture-raised eggs organic non-gmo tofu
oh and the house-made sauces you can't
find anywhere else and it's all personal
I son basket lets you mix and match from
paleo lean and clean gluten-free vegan
vegetarian Mediterranean and more sorry
got my Invisalign in not to mention
tons of variety with 18 recipes to
choose from best of all each delicious
easy recipe is ready in about 30 minute
I gave you more here there's more right
there go to Sun basket dot-com / birth
and today to learn more and get $35 off
your first order that Sun basket calm /
/ for $35 off Sun basket dr. Khan / BER
okay movement watches everybody you guys
have heard me talk about movement
you know who's you know those two
college dropouts you didn't eat all of
that it's right here it's right there
there you go you know it's to college
dropouts that started their own watch
company this company has grown like
crazy and now almost two million watches
sold in hundred sixty countries they
continue to revolutionize the fashion
world you have got it right here you
gotta join in the countries to
revolutionize a fashion on belief that
style shouldn't break the bank buddy I
don't know if you check this site out
lately but they have doubled the number
of watch styles and are still expanding
movement watches start at just $95 good
lord here move it figured out that by
selling online they were able to cut out
the middleman and retail markup at the
best part for the best possible price
classic design quality construction
styled minimalism get 15% off today you
like that part Enya with free shipping
and free returns go to Mugen watches
calm such first see why the movement
keeps growing check out their expanding
collection go to MVM t.com / / join okay
and lastly but certainly not least Lee
LegalZoom in national small business
month at LegalZoom is here hi hi whether
you're just starting out I already have
a business says a lot you can take
advantage of right now just go to
legalzoom.com / startup during march
match to download your free business
startup kit you'll get a ton of great
information for example you can find out
how to maximize your business
deductibles under the new tax laws
you'll get great discounts your kit
includes special deals from LegalZoom
along with their service partners so you
can save a bunch of money financing
marketing and operating your business
LegalZoom isn't a law firm but they know
you need to you need to tap into the
right resources to run a successful
business that's why their business
startup kit that's what their business
startup kit is all about go to
legalzoom.com slash startup to download
your free business startup kit today
there's no obligation just free business
sources this offer is only available in
March so if you're listening after then
you can still enjoy special savings by
using the code birbee URR when you check
out at legalzoom.com well tell me what
are you doing to work out dude you're
like shredded well I have a gym in my
house and what I and and I I okay what I
do okay so I lift weights that
definitely I live I have eight steps to
help right you got another book about
this IRA mention sex drums in rock and
roll is his book the hardest hitting man
in show business Kenny Aronoff do I left
that out of the book that's why I'm
writing a second book they cut 300 300
pages out of that book I mean I'm 300
million records sold dude so so I I'm
just a workaholic you know and and so
they said it's too long the the magic
number was 300 325 pages I want they
left out this whole scene with me and
Cameron Diaz me meeting Dave Grohl when
he comes up to me I'm hungover I just
played with the Buddy Rich big band in
New York
me and Matt soaring around all night
just partying it up and I'm hungover
checking out and David skinny Dave Grohl
comes up to me goes hey Kenny stays with
him we do uh oh hi Dave yeah I'm flying
ha ha all right you guys stay in town I
got this showcase now you gotta come
he's a jumping around go Jackrabbit and
I just got new band masses are
what's the name I know it's full
fighters madman that's a weird name see
ya
that didn't make the book they said you
just name dropping manic they said you
can't have I've admitted yeah but nerds
like me I want to hear right no worries
did the camera Diaz you like to it was a
basically I turned you know III didn't
you know the Sunset Marquis mmm the
whiskey bar the whiskey whiskey bar in
the Sunset Marquis Hotel is the bar and
a Sunset Marquis you know that that's a
hotel it's a kind of boutique hotel all
the rockers go if you on alta loma' go
down the hill off of sunset in there
okay it was I mean every I mean you
walked in there beat Jeff back it'd be
you too it'd be the stones it was and
only could hold 75 people's really
intimate all the rock bands would stay
there so I'm staying there and I'm doing
a record with Tony Iommi and Billy
Corgan from the PAMP pumpkins Tony I'm
from Sabbath so doing a solo record
and those that was a 13 hour session
that one day with 45 minute break you
know this is this is to be real bad as
such but and you know you know
no no vocals to listen to it was just
we're writing the song right there three
movements and Billy doesn't [ __ ] around
it's not a party time it's [ __ ] all
work so that night I'm sitting in there
having a drink with Tony and a whole
bunch of [ __ ] happened that night I
think that might be in the book but I
also see Toby Myers I just left the
Mellencamp band two years prior and I've
been in that band for 17 years so it was
like a divorce also I see the bass
player come running out of the bar I'm
in the in the lobby because it was it
was too filled and he's like [ __ ] this
he's pissed I'm like Toby what's going
on man just [ __ ] get the elevator
takes off I'm like wow what's going on I
walk in there and there's the Mellencamp
man so that was kind of an emotional
yeah it's you know I don't know how you
don't get divorced and seeing your
ex-wife suddenly and a new drummer you
know and he's it's awkward you know then
I look over out in the courtyard news
the the tour manager for the pumpkins
about 6-8 and he brings me over bond
line is
he's smiling he just wanted to see would
be like I saw Cameron Diaz oh she's just
done that big first movie Something
About Mary and some guys talking to her
and the bottom line is it was Jimmy
Chamberlin from the pumpkins he wanted
to see us connect you know me what would
happen right anyway he said he said some
drinks and stuff and he's just talking
and I I was just so uptight from this
though everything going on that day and
then that I can't ban him like yeah you
know and bottom line is Jimmy and I he
tapped on Jimmy Jimmy and I just can't
talk but it was didn't work out the way
I wanted to so I stood there and went
that's not how I wanted me Jimmy
Chamberlin a cool down with tapped him
on the shoulder said Jimmy listen man I
I respect you so much you are one of my
favorite almost badass I feel so honored
to be playing in your band dude I just
goddamn I didn't I'm sorry I met you
like this you know I would love to just
tell you how much I appreciate you and
then I walked off it's about 2:00 in the
morning the bar closes up comes Cameron
Diaz lands on my lap Jesus cross your
arms around me lands one lap now I'm
1998 so I was like just a ball of
testosterone and my normal game of play
was like if a chick lands on your lap at
2:00 in the morning what do you think
you're gonna say or do right it's so
excited eh gorgeous hot and she whispers
you know with that smile on those lips
and she whispers in my ear and somebody
would have probably thought she was
kissing me whispers to my assistant he
said to Jimmy that was really really
cool and I look at her I smile and
that's usually I go hey I got a room
upstairs
I can get some liquor you want to eat
you want some what what do you want yeah
yeah and I'd put my move I didn't put
that in the book they said well you
didn't have sex when I'm like the part
the reason why I should have put that my
book is this the reason why I didn't
stand into her which was not normal for
me was I have [ __ ] session the next
day thirteen hours with Billy Corgan at
Tony Iommi
oh and the point of this book is work
came over everything
Welsh if everything turned down the
potential of that yeah you're definitely
a workaholic you lose one sentence I'm
hoping canidius like come find me
someday while I'm given one of my
speeches on stage and says I'm here to
collect yeah we'll probably be in
wheelchairs and they have colostomy bags
and I'll be yeah and that's so much now
hey you uh but you were talking about
working out yeah what about diet and all
that alright so in the book I came up
with eight things first thing number one
lifting weights the reason why I lifting
weights is important though I just swore
off it because I [ __ ] up my rotator
cuff so he's telling other types of
weight lifting wakes you can do the pink
ones so the 1-pounders oh I think I can
handle those at this point three hundred
reps gets ran reps okay get that wire
restring yeah there's all kinds of
things I have banned so I go on the road
to take it in my hotel oh I can do
everything in my hotel them so anyway I
just lifting weights
besides being strong it keeps your
hormone levels up and when your hormone
levels up you're fighting the big three
diseases cancer diabetes and heart
disease
mm-hmm it's proven so our hormone levels
go down real quick you know it's before
year definitely near twenty [ __ ] starts
changing testosterone levels start going
down after 18 or 17 or so it's crazy but
anyway it keeps your hormones up which
makes you younger too everything about
it makes you youthful alright so lifting
weights does that it also the more
muscle mass you build the more it chews
on fat and eat your fat okay so you know
and I know how to carve my body I know
that you know you do you know bench
press for your chest you do you know you
do pull you know you pull downs to get
to create that V you do you know you
know I do bench also to build your chest
fly I do flies and bench I know how to
carve my body alright the second thing
is a card like Jim do you have like that
[ __ ] from like the 80s that old was at
the wieder Joe you know things have fun
all of that outsold the crayon great
memory grey on grey sweats I used to
work in gyms like that
in Indiana that was old school gym with
Olympians would work in those like
called the iron pit no new nothing
pretty about it these are guys that want
to work out you know but I had a trainer
for a long time so I'd look for 14 years
so I learned how to do it right and I
need to get a new one because I need to
be you know get the latest techniques
you know it's all about technique as you
all know rotator cuff you know people
don't you know I can help you with bad
technique yeah you want to get hurt I
can [ __ ] I've been guy once I've gone
three injuries in a row and now I think
I'm fine you know you when you bench
pressed did you or do you when you did
anyways you used to probably raise your
shoulders right my shoulders were
already up talking
the thing about lifting weights is you
either as a trauma I was in a protective
posture like an orange hair when I was
growing up I mean I was just
goddamn bullseye yeah you were bullseye
you know [ __ ] this weight [ __ ] you right
between brothers to shrink you go see
him he'll help you out I'm done talking
those [ __ ] few I know because you're
always gonna have problems and then they
always got to sit there and then then
you start doing it to other people
oh you know what that is that's because
when you work 80 and that ice cream fell
off you [ __ ] Conan and you just
become this this person trying to
connect everything so I know I did I've
just sort of accepted Who I am I try to
work on being less of an angry [ __ ]
yeah is what I'm trying to do I've
gotten way better I feel you're married
right yeah yeah how is she dealing with
it the angry [ __ ] now she's a angry
[ __ ] too
now she's a saint man I think he's did
kids know if she ever just said look I
just can't [ __ ] deal with you anymore
I would I would be the law probably but
I get it yeah I get it yeah I get it
yeah but I mean you know then there's
the other part of me it's just like well
you know we're living nice here
yeah and I'm out here it'd be [ __ ]
goddamn every other weekend and I suck
getting mad again you know I'm out here
[ __ ] Dayton Ohio
doin [ __ ] dick jokes yeah you're
watching every episode of The Office
which doesn't get you anywhere
good for a sec I gave up I gave up
arguing with my wife for Lent and
I said I'm just I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna I'm finding the genius I used to
think those guys were just likes like
they they just quit boy just those guys
it's not worth it it's not worth it
it says actually there's the game within
the game when you do that it's because
man it's heavy if you can do that
because your emotions are raging your
brain isn't as powerful as your emotions
but their thing is is how they get you
okay
it's because they can't physically beat
the show generally speaking English in
Dayton some UFC chicks like they can't
beat the [ __ ] out who I know so they
have to go cerebral and what happens is
is you give up all your information when
you're wrong when you I mean when you're
mad yes and then I collect that yeah oh
yeah so the thing is is when you don't
lose your [ __ ] anymore all of a sudden
they're there they're the information
trail that the court has been cut now
they don't know what the [ __ ] you
thinking look and this is like this holy
[ __ ] I think I finally got some power
back in this this is incredible so I
think the big thing is you recognize
that yeah that's the big thing because
what I'm doing now it's like the
execution that I'll go like yeah you
don't say anything
yeah you still get smart you go all
right you start to learn how to beat
acting like that wreak some out oh dude
because all of a sudden respect you
don't yeah they don't like but then what
they do is then what all you did was
catch up to one of their skills yes one
and then what happens is then you know
they immediately adjusting their it
becomes a different that it's we it's
all its evolving they're professional at
what they do and we're just learning how
to do better it's like get in the ring
with Muhammad Ali I mean you might get
one punch in then it's lights out yeah
you know well you know that is my
experience but yeah my big thing now is
try this as I know there's that point
where I can feel the [ __ ]
testosterone blowing and threw me my
muscle swelling and she's a couple
glasses of wine she's like completely
out out of control and I'm perfect and
she uh I just go just at one moment I
just go she I shut the computer or the
book or whatever I'm doing I said see
and I leave I get I pulled myself out of
the room oh you can walk oh I gotta walk
because if I don't I've always
wanted to do the walk I've never I've
never been able do it we said you say
you know what
I'll see if I'm going or just leave so
I'm done that's what I say I'm done I'm
done I leave because if I don't know I
got to do the clap yeah I like the clap
I'm done I'm done seen see but that's
good for both of us because what happens
if see I'll be up all night stewing
about it
not her she's goes to sleep wakes up oh
honey
and I'm like still raging right I can't
get past that I just I wish I could just
stop going in the gym I doing here what
this all right I talked to myself I will
I walk down the street one time and I
didn't even give a [ __ ] who heard me and
I know there was people looking at me I
didn't care I was just like she's
practicing it's like I will never do
this again yeah okay I understand people
getting married the first time you
didn't know what you were getting into
but people who get the second time it's
like you you got three oh my god I am
[ __ ] one and done if this show
doesn't wear I must say we're in a bad
place but if she ever just said [ __ ]
this I'm out I would totally get it and
I would just I would give her everything
yeah and I would I would have somebody
build me this the drum room no the dream
divorcee house for the guy which is just
a garage with the [ __ ] room above it
yeah it's a big studio that my daughter
electronic drum kits I don't piss
anybody off
I laugh all the [ __ ] sports packages
little kegerator slowly drink myself to
death and a nice car tonight it's my old
[ __ ] 68 f100 you can you want
everything [ __ ] thing else take it I
don't give a [ __ ]
well you know what I feel the same way
if I don't if I don't if I if you know
my wife she's 21 years younger
she's hot as hell Gina if she left me I
just say I tell you have to worry about
me cheating on you because if you leave
me I'm done I'll never [ __ ] live with
another woman again and you know and
rightfully so a strikethrough you're out
I mean I'd be like now I'm not saying
that then the date and do what guys do
but I would live alone you don't deserve
to live with anybody it's no I'll take
half the blame I don't
I'm not on my perk I'm not good enough
I'm not equipped for this next life I'll
do it right now because you know my
career has always been first I mean is
that what messed up most everything it's
always been it's always been my career's
been first and we can attach that
towards Authority and [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ]
career has always been first and that's
what got me where I am and now I'm
that's what I love about my wife is she
gets that because I've seen other guys
deal with that where it's just like they
get with somebody and they love the
lifestyle of what you do but then they
want that nine-to-five guy who's going
to be like honey I'm home every night
eat then once state after awhile they
just get tired of that and then that's
what [ __ ] makes me paranoid about
women is because then they leave you but
they take the lifestyle with them and
you're the guy that earned it and now
you have to continue going out doing
what the [ __ ] it is you do while you
give all the lifestyle money to them and
then they meet this other [ __ ] at
nine-to-five [ __ ] and they get to
live this Rockstar [ __ ] and and you know
cake and eat it yeah okay kitty that's
reality that's that's a definite that is
a definite reality if you bring that up
it's considered like misogynistic and
all that type of [ __ ] don't just that's
the thing that's that all of this me to
[ __ ] that's going on right now whether
they're examining the male-female
dynamic which obviously needs to be done
it's obviously a good thing too I mean I
I had no idea all this [ __ ] [ __ ] was
going on that's all good but what I love
about this it's like we're gonna examine
the male-female dynamic but it's it's
they're only going to critique what guys
do in the relationship so at that point
you're kind of suggesting that women are
like these completed works and meanwhile
they're [ __ ] killing us every guy
dies before their wife they always
outlive us they blame I say you don't go
to the [ __ ] doctor you know I'm going
to the doctor I'm going I'm getting
everything [ __ ] checked out I'm gonna
just just to [ __ ] prove them wrong my
wife is still gonna kill me I swear to
god she is I tell my life all my shut I
tell everyone to live long and all you
[ __ ] I got that old man I'm a [ __ ]
live I'm just just
be hangin on Dominus I'm like hang on
hey okay yeah I'll be paralyzed on one
side don't kill me
communicating through your little bell
like that through to break it bad yeah I
know it's pretty crazy I mean you know
it's just typical of anything like this
it swings way over to the other side and
and and there's definitely some
definitely some issues and things to be
addressed I mean without mentioning
names bad behavior is bad behavior I
agree
bad behavior is bad behavior but this
it's get to the point where then you've
got so many gray areas and so many
things to consider that aren't just
what's going on the news that guys it's
not just there's something else going on
in and they're trying to like just just
put it all into one little cubicle I'm
gonna get my ass kicked for this but you
know it's not I want you to get in
trouble here I don't want you not
getting me interested let me ask you
this what do you think music today what
are some of the banjos ever he's always
trying oh my god what happened to music
and bah bah bah bah what do you what do
you like in music this day is I think
mediocrity is in and what did you do
that was because all the studios used to
have like the [ __ ] guy you wanted to
produce your record and now it's like
it's just [ __ ] people at home no it's
real simple what you're right but the
reason the reason behind all the change
or one of the big reasons behind the
change is that you don't buy CDs there's
no income coming in I'm on three CDs
that sold 40 million apiece to Celine
Dion records and a meatloaf pad on how
to each sold over 40 million not
including downloads think about now if
the artist is making 18 cents on the
dollar that's 82 cents to the label
times 40 mil that's gonna pay some bills
the business model was analyzed with
Mellencamp
you could spend we could spend a year
making the record you know cuz we were
doing in Indiana which is cheaper but
actually we did it in other places but
we could spend a year working on a
record if we made a record and music
suck you throw it away and start again
and also by the way back then if you
a good course a good hook line good a
unique sound unique this unique that
unique that you wouldn't even get played
on the radio because everybody else was
doing that you're competing against the
greatest records that have have come out
in a long time it's so but there was
money that's my point and when the
record came out there was a million
dollars you could invest if they wanted
to a million dollars to get that record
playing on the radio across the United
States not to mention the marketing plan
for the Europe and in Asia and England
and Australia then when you went on tour
there was tour support there was money
to invest in a band to build a career
and the way it is nothing more powerful
than a bunch of guys working together
let's see Beatles stones you too you
know the who oh yeah I mean these bands
did Led Zeppelin I mean these bands work
together didn't even matter if they got
along the point is all the talent in one
room created this incredible team that
created incredible epic product when one
guy can't do what four guys that's like
Michael Jordan was the most dangerous
basketball player in the world why he
figured it out wasn't about him was
about the team and that's what scared
the other people like a coach of the
piston saying that one year when Mike
showed up the first game they played him
they collapsed the D on him and he
passed the ball in my court oh [ __ ] of
course he's still dominated and tooked
over the game but employees he started
doing that he added that hold on yeah to
his game and it was over his point is
you look at him you know he's going to
do the right thing for the team that's
scary man because that means he's he's a
coach and a player so I mean the the
teams are greater than individual one
guy thinks that he can do as much as
five that's crazy but because of the
budgets we've been forced into those
cubicles we've been forced to people
have to there is no budget I have a
studio right up the road there and
people come over and they and they David
they want me to record drums have an
engineer I have a control room in a drum
moon and I've done like Sammy Hagar
Billy Gibbons Steve Lukather all kinds
of but I most the work I get his people
sending me files from all over the world
when they save up their little money and
they have you know forty four decades of
experience and my sister literally write
a song and be like I want to get Kenny
Aronoff on this and they send you a
little zip whatever the [ __ ] they're
called zip file if I reciprocate or
whatever the [ __ ] they call they send
you that day huh I load it into my Pro
Tools so I asked this I asked for the
click they used on the session because
man the times I haven't gotten a click
it's a disaster if they didn't play a
click track oh [ __ ] and it's speed is
just long and it takes me longer so
because of the budget I want I would
love to see you and your drum room jesus
[ __ ] Friday you slow it down again
something like that Wow so I get to
click I want to click to use the session
I put that into Pro Tools on one track
and I can control the volume and then I
sell them to send me the demo with the
drum sequencer stuff that they use
because 9 out of 10 times that's what
they're in love with then send me the
song without the drums because that's
what I'm gonna play too
I'm gonna play the song without the drum
sequence and the click do you do before
you know you play what they already put
down oh yeah do you play what you would
play first so you don't have their [ __ ]
in your head
no I play first I do is I play exactly
what they program then I start making
adjustments like instead of open high
and I might go to the crash cymbal or go
to the ride cymbal or the first take I
give them three tanks first take is
pretty much what they had but it with my
feel and then I start doing like more
fills that are me I do different things
I'm thinking they could pick from this
and the third take I go even further and
that's that's that's my really my
definition of creativity is to start
with the foundation and then build off
of that and sometimes iq4 takes if I
think you know what and and then I send
it back to them and they typically go
for take two the three is I've gone too
far or they might grab like he was doing
the strong for Sammy Hagar and I said
you know I really think this song he
just sent me guitar and his vocal and a
click he can still sing is that
ridiculous so just like music just here
in ridiculous
let me know next time you guys are
playing I don't do this looks like I was
playing with him the guy's been stolen
timber pilots some guys from the cult
some guys from Matt storm and I were
playing together Steve Stevens I mean
something from the stones it was great
it was a music thing I mean to get kids
you know instruments in schools but I
thought you were describing what all you
guys are doing it was a music thing oh
yeah I didn't think you guys are playing
basketball so anyways I so I got those
really interesting so they usually end
up taking like tattoos which makes sense
because they're not drummers and then
you you but they know what they want and
then you should see I gotta show you
what I'm up with my charts on those anal
chart writer in the planet this is
because hey why you look for that I want
to ask a question yeah then I drum up
for the longest [ __ ] time I've always
wanted to ask her drama with your setup
I don't know if you still do this yeah I
do you verse yeah why do you for people
at home listening he would have like
what every 12 12 inch to 10 inch 10 inch
going and you're a right handed drummer
going left to right while it's 30
minutes takes me there and then I beat
it and make it sound like I'm not
reading make it feel like I'm not
reading that's you're looking at is drum
sure all that is so [ __ ] cool for
Chinese like yeah so are you
so usually for people who don't play
drums listen to this you go high low
high to low so yeah yeah so you he's a
10 12 14 16 going down and you go like
12 10 16 18 16 18 so what happened was
that gotten Mellencamp Ben and I I went
I auditioned I showed up with a car with
leaky oil and I had this big-ass you
know Neil Peart from Rush drumset John
looks at me looks at the car looks at
the drums shakes my hand John Mellencamp
turns around walks the other direction
like wow he was not happy
I didn't look cool the car is leaking on
his driveway and I got a drumset that's
like right you know he's not cool since
this guy's not gonna work out I crushed
it though I just beat the SH a broke
everything
he was just close to me is Moslems open
like holy [ __ ] who this guy's into it
anyway I get in the band but
immediately said it was another time
when someone's just look at you like no
and you just yeah go went over the top
that book you see where he cut me from
the first record five weeks later and he
told me to go home I said at nine going
home I'm not [ __ ] going home
still where's gonna be mortified I'd
rather go to Mars there's no where we're
going because I didn't have enough I
didn't I didn't know how to serve a song
you know what I tell a drummer and we'll
get back to the tenants Tom I say you
know what the purpose of the drummers
when you're making a record nobody ever
gets it they're gonna get it now cuz
I've said it enough but they go beat and
loggia time I says no get the [ __ ]
song on the radio to be number one
that's your job because when you do that
you just made the company millions of
dollars you just made the record label
or you made the artist or the band
millions of dollars if Microsoft hired
us they don't give a [ __ ] cause they
just want us to make money and they
smile and when we make money for them
they give us some money we take care of
our family it's that simple and then
nobody ever tells you that [ __ ] but
that's why I didn't get on the first
record I played with Leonard Bernstein I
was at angled I got the Jews from
Symphony Orchestra what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with getting a song on
the radio to be number one
I didn't know I was looking through a
telescope and that is looking through a
microscope were you so different
direction isn't it and and I didn't
understand that and I eventually did
obviously but I went I'm a fighter fight
guy I didn't know that so I wrote this
book I thought I'm just asking I can't
wait to read this I can't wait to laugh
you tell me - John said I he'd like
Charlie Watts he wanted the Charlie
Watts one rack Tom one floor tongue one
ride cymbal when crash at Hyatt that's
it so that was really tough because you
know drummers are really particular
about to set up so when I I was really
pissed about that but okay I did it and
and then we went on tour see maybe I did
the first tour with one rat calm but
then Jack and Diane which is the next
record I vowed I'd be on the next record
which I was who says that big drum solo
boom bland do you bet you did you did
you did you have to do better - boo
and it was for time so I contacted you
sing [ __ ] and [ __ ] alright so so I'm
playing or maybe this is what happened
before Jack then I'm in well I had a
12-inch rack Tom a 16 inch floor Tom and
an 18s didn't even have hardware on the
bottom I I just didn't haven't even have
a deal yet
didn't even have hardware and and I had
the Evans hydraulic heads remember those
fat dick heads depend have the oil in
the middle yeah yeah and and it's like
and so the engineer comes up to me and
we're playing open up so you're 18 is
like a concert time like there's nothing
no bottom head no bottom and that figure
didn't study we're opening up for the
kinks so we're playing in big venues and
the engineer comes up to me goes Kenny
your toms I can't get enough definition
out of those drums you got a smaller Tom
and I went what I do but John doesn't
want it and this is when I add the rack
come on a snare stand mmm I didn't mind
I didn't want it was old school so I
said well I got a smaller time but
John's not gonna like it and then I went
hey tell John is vocal to sound way
better if I have that 10-inch time up
there I'm just joking and I don't know
if he told him that but the bomb lies he
says put the other time up so but I
didn't have a hold of fortune I had to
put on a snare stand so I've got a 24
inch kick drum and these times are like
you could drive a freight train through
a tweener but why but why wouldn't you
just put the 10 because at this point I
realized the the value and the
perfection of snare 1216 is the sound
like a jazz drummer and how you go back
to then want dummies they were all into
like not what looks good but what sounds
good putting a 10-inch right there with
a 12-inch
I wasn't gonna go for it I wouldn't hide
go ten I guess I could have put the
hi-hat outs farther and then squeezed
the 10-inch even far left and leave the
twelve weirdest but I decided to reverse
it yeah and then probably avoided hip
problems too cuz then you like just
being just another two inches after
forty years all of a sudden its ah [ __ ]
I can't walk yeah so yeah that became my
thing and then think about if you put
your hand out
10 then left hand 12 right hand 16
baboon does that but I'm sure that some
of the fields I did was so out there
some guy in Japan was trying to try to
analyze this chick on ynu right you try
to figure out the sticking I hate when
that happens and you have like like all
that you know the whole bought the
bottom the yeah kick right left and they
went kick left right everybody in
England went kick left right so it had
that descending sound that way I do it
like Bonham yeah I go left hand on the
rack come what I got to get yeah I go
left hand right hand back for it that's
what bonded and you know that that that
filly he does in a black black dog goes
uh-uh uh-uh
that's that's no duh yeah he leads with
his left hand so he go left to the rack
Tom left which is that did you do that
to be was that to be with that it's let
snare
Tom's snare foot but then he can lose it
right on snare foot no [ __ ] because I
sold share snare Tom so he doesn't like
that because he's so talented
he just thought well why cross over my
hands and why he just made his hands do
what execute a thing to get the sound he
wanted so you want to go death to do
Google ooh God so he didn't left-handed
that that good dude that did good as
opposed to mostly to go suck to lose out
to Ducks they don't wanna know all the
leading with the right hand the right
handed second of all it it's easier so
but not bono no he's dr. booth dr. dot
so why did you ever see those guys live
Zeppelin just [ __ ] the first time you
haven't been sitting up straight
yeah you just least some of you I never
saw dude to me give us like death that
Royal Albert Hall that just a way that
that concert looks so you know the DVD
that released about 15 years ago and his
drum sound it's just I you know what's
funny about that guy I was talking to
something about this there's like this
whole like
I think it's a myth that he played like
these to be giant tree trunks to be look
at his thinks like he's playing like a 5
mm ask you something
do you remember what heads he's using in
that that that is that how the West was
won that thing that doesn't that all
came up back then okay do you know what
to him heads he had on the Royal Albert
Hall or any of that time well he you
still have the black dot look okay okay
that's right did have that in some
thought remains the same he had okay on
the oil on the how the West is one
coated ambassador not only do you have
coated ambassador he on his kick drum to
do died blow through that [ __ ] in like
three songs coated ambassador and he had
it oh and the snare drum you remember
when you're a little kid you placed
there don't like it you don't change the
head because gonna put that hard you had
to stare them and it turns black and
then the inside of that black gets beat
out clear and you could see through the
dry meet you that drummer heads been on
there for 80 years
he had a snare drum live with that look
and that starts studying his muscles and
hit the weight wasn't hitting that hard
getting an incredible foot but he wasn't
hitting that hard because you cannot
play a coat and ambassador heads and and
make it and have it last in a live show
like they were doing he couldn't hit
that hard his hair was flying around it
looked like he was just a beast and he's
big but I Watson's muscles and his
everybody moves
that's all wrists and fingers I played
for my belly button I'm like martial
arts player right started off with
mallets when instead of November you had
to lift with your wrist because to get
the the yarn off of the wooden bar so I
developed this technique tympani I use
fingers to get the stick to just bounce
off the timpani use your fingers and
then with stare dome you do both because
when you do double stroke low you go
wrist down and then fingers to get the
rebound and then when I start playing
rock and roll I started to use that
wrist thing and I started to go into my
forearm then into my upper arm and then
I stood going with my back and that
struck once
I'm gonna do the boost Li thing start
playing for my gut and that's you know
that's how I just think what little I
know obviously I just think he just knew
Bonham just knew how to hit a drum you
want to hit it and get the [ __ ] out of
the way of it and let it yep
cuz I might what my generation coming up
in the 80s all like all this deal we
would that's what was that thing when
people just you know you'd hit the bass
drum and leave the beater on it me too
and you try to like just just bash you
because his sound was so big it was also
- I mean that was production value - and
everything so what we were sitting at 20
26 inch bass drum you know yeah we were
trying to get that sound yeah we just
thought yeah you had to hit hard and
never buying these big stupid like those
marching band sticks came and it just
sounded like absolute [ __ ] I would just
sound like I was hitting a wet piece of
notebook paper when I would hit it and
it just would never work but it was
that's the whole point of this thing is
it look what you hear isn't what you
doesn't add up to what you actually do
to get that sound this is so many very
let me ask you a few more before before
we gotta wrap this up because I could
literally talk to you about who's a most
underrated drummer there's a lot of
underrated drummer Phil Rudd for ac/dc
unbelievable unbelievable it's what more
like what he doesn't do okay I just saw
I just did music Kara's in New York Don
was this beautiful director producer
hires me to do these big huge things we
all play with 20 artists all kinds of
styles you know the Merle Haggard
recently Greg almond dr. John Fleetwood
Mac that's my whole point for music
cares and I watched Fleetwood Mac
rehearse acted we were done rehearsing I
played with eight artists I want to
watch them and then Mick Fleetwood
Walker 1990 here's another guy who
switched the Tom's right yeah yeah yeah
and any as I have to have that extension
on his hi-hat cuz he was like nine yeah
like you need feet tall dick ulis
but the thing is is that these drummers
were guys I became the drummer I used to
make fun of when I was in college like
[ __ ] that Nigel also said this guy
Charlie Watts you know even Ringo who I
thought was my idol he is my
was but then I went on like yummy Billy
Cobham pretty much [ __ ] up my career
because I was trying to play like I'm
saying yeah you know that's a younger
that's a young person yes like if I
gotta go I gotta go plays many notes as
I can and showing off yeah in doing all
that I obviously not trashing Billy car
I told Billy karma says you must [ __ ]
up my crew it's in my book I said but
you know and we're friends I there's no
way I was ever gonna be like Billy come
and I learned a lot by trying my point
is is that I had to learn to appreciate
how brilliant a guy like Charlie Watts
or Ringo Starr's
and that Phil Rudd and there's a whole
slew of my favorite thing about Phil
Rudd is when they're coming out of like
the verse or something or something like
that so at that point you you think that
he's gonna hit the crash and he doesn't
know it's playing and then when he
finally does he's just built up so much
tension
yeah and then the song just like it just
[ __ ] takes off it took me four I used
to I used to yeah I mean obviously I
became a comedian so I made a lot didn't
make that mistake no but I didn't learn
I didn't learn that until you know I was
probably a comedian for 15 years and I
you know there's that initial thing
where you play to ac/dc because you you
think it's easy yeah you think and you
think you're playing it but you're not
playing but physically you're doing it
and it took the longest time until I saw
guys like Steve Jordan and even Steve
Gadd one time would just play the most
simple beat and I just would watch those
guys an example right there being like I
can physically play that but I could
never even remotely make it sound it all
come after head first you got to hear it
somebody saw me doing I did another
MusiCares I was honoring Dylan here in
LA some drummers I decided in between
the rehearsal and the filming and
recording these shows by the way 16
cameras you they're gonna record it you
can't [ __ ] up and you just finished
rehearsing with three artists and now
you got that's why I write everything
out you know so anyway this guy's I
decided I talked to the engineer said I
just feel like in this room I similar to
a bike I'm gonna put up some kasem bolt
you tell me so I'm playing the simple
groove just laying it down being doing
what I do and some drummer for the
other band it's looking at me shaking
his head and he comes over and I said
it's something wrong with the cymbals he
goes no how the [ __ ] you make those
drums sound like that how do you get
that sound you're not doing anything
fancy so he was telling me what I'm in
are of other drums like you know and I
said you know how do I do that says cuz
I hear something I imagine something in
my head maybe it's John Bonham and I
imagine something in my heart and I'm
just chasing after it I'm not chasing
after every hit everything I'm always
going does that sound like I wanted to
sound and feel the way I want to feel so
it doesn't matter what notes I'm playing
isn't cheating on directing myself
making adjustments with my right hand my
left hand my right foot my left foot
everything my posture everything to get
that kind of sound am I getting that
sound that I'm feeling and imagining
yeah but rather than just doing just
doing it yeah Wow you know as a pet
peeve of mine is still is to this day
when you watch a music video which you
don't see a lot of them the amount of
[ __ ] times where they never had the
drummer's synced incorrectly like you
said on a snare and he's always hitting
the kick and vice-versa it's just like
and it's just too [ __ ] worth or you
hear him playing the hi-hat and he's
[ __ ] crashing assembled ate this they
never have any [ __ ] respect for a
drummer and I got to tell you something
dude the amount of respect I I already
had for you and just listen you know
your whole background and how all this
stuff you've overcome and your whole
attitude towards is that you're
inspirational guy and and and you're
saying that Jack and Diane fell at me
now I'm [ __ ] completed it is
fantastic he's got a new book out called
sex drums and rock and roll Kenny
Aronoff thank you so much for coming on
the podcast and I should say that you
know you say speaking inspirational I've
been doing a lot of is the article in
Forbes I sent you that I don't forgot it
I said I'm gonna have a look at eating
else I'll look for it not emails
detector but my point is I've been doing
a lot of speaking that book gave me the
inspiration to go out and I have a whole
show I'm gonna do Marathon Oil in two
days well I have a whole hour and 15
minute so where's Christ I'm gonna be
opening for you so let me do 20 minutes
20 I can't believe I forgot I was I was
joking telling you I have
VHS copies that I bought like I don't
know how many I put them in the 90s but
it was like you'll be a Power yeah I
want until a [ __ ] I got it we got a
hangout so fun cuz I got it I want to do
this I never do autographs I just want
things I do care now thank you so much
alright guys thank you for listening